[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Bruno rotaillot bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sénateur de laavandé
président du groupe les républicains ici
au Sénat on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par votre presse régionale
Stéphane Vernet de wouest-fance bonjour
Stéphane bonjour bonjour bonjour
Stéphane Vernet on a évidemment beaucoup
de sujets d'actualité à avoir avec vous
et on commence par cette question du
terrorisme puisqu'hier malheureusement
une nouvelle attaque terroriste a frappé
l'Europe en Belgique deux suédois ont
été tués Emmanuel Macron estime que
l'Europe est bousculée vous aussi bien
sûr elle est bousculée mais
elle est bousculée mais elle n'a pas
pris par anticipation loin de là toutes
les mesures de précaution pour protéger
ses peuples l'Europe s'est bâti avec un
logiciel qui est un logiciel je dirais
néolibéral défacement des frontières
défacement des frontières commerciales
on est la zone douanière la moins
protégée au monde on a détruit beaucoup
d'emplois dans l'industrie à cause de
cela mais effacement des frontières avec
l'accueil de quantités énorme d'immigrés
sur le sol européen et c'est cette
naïveté aujourd'hui que l'Europe paye
elle le paye au prix cher vous attendez
une à une multiplication des passages à
l'acte est-ce que est-ce que nous sommes
entrés dans un nouveau cycle de de
violence terroriste en Europe selon vous
il y a pas de nouveau cycle en en
réalité on a jamais depuis les Twin
Towers finalement c'est une succession
d'attentat mais on voit bien qu'il y a
une répétition qui s'accélère il y a
effectivement des périodes d'alcalmie il
y a des périodes de de paroxistiqu comme
on le vit et
on bien sûr puisque bien sûr puisque ce
qui se passe en Israël c'est pas du tout
la cause palestinien une guerre de
libération d'un peuple opprimé c'est pas
ça du tout le Hamas c'est un mouvement
islamiste est-ce que vous savez ce que
signifie le mot Hamas le mot Hamas c'est
un acronyme qui signifie mouvent
mouvement de résistance islamique il a
jamais été question pour le fondateur et
l'inspirateur du Hamas qui est le cheik
Yassine qui est désormais décédé de
libérer la Palestine non son projet
était de faire de toute la Palestine y
compris d'ailleurs de l'État d'Israël
une terre de la charia voilà donc c'est
bien là encore le projet islamiste comme
on a pu le voir en Irak qui est réactivé
et toutes les cellules dorm
aujourd'hui en France se réveille en
France vous faites un lien vous faites
un lien vous entre ce qui se passe
actuellement entre Israël et le Hamas et
ce qui se passe ce qui s'est passé àas
ce qui se passe en Belgique mais mais
bien sûr le lien d'illeur évident
puisque professeur Bernard mort était
assassiné par cette barbarie islamiste
était vendredi le jour où un des
inspirateurs et fondateurs du Hamas
avait déclaré ce vendredi 13 comme
journée de colère il faudrait être
aveugle et nous sommes encore trop
aveugles en France et en Europe on n pas
pris la mesure de cette menace nous
c'est qui les dirigeants que ce soit les
dirigeants européens ou que ce soi les
dirigeants français Emmanuel Macron il
est encore àveugle mais écoutez bien sûr
il a un discours de fermeté ces derniers
jour intraitable pour vous c'est que ce
sont des mots discours mais il a un
discours qui s'adapte à la à
l'opportunité présente
mais encore une fois c'est à l'école que
un professeur de français a été tué
c'est donc l'école qui est visée or
c'est le même manuel Macron qui avait
nommé monsieur papendia qui avait un
rapport avec la laïité extrêmement lâche
regardez ce qu'il a fait du Conseil des
SAGE de la laïcité regardez son peu
d'empressement à prendre des sanctions
des décisions vis-à-vis des élèves qui
portaient les tenue longue les Abas les
camis et bien monsieur a été nommé après
Jean-Michel Blanquer qui était plutôt
intraitable sur les questions de la cité
il a été nommé par le même Emmanuel
Macron un homme politique Gabriel Atal
Gabriel Atal il fait mieux les choses
selon vous sur en tout cas il a bien
commencé il a bien
commencé il faut poursuivre vous savez
il y a la BAA mais moi je lui demande
par exemple d'aller plus loin on a voté
au Sénat il à plusieurs reprises des
textes des amendement pour
l'interdiction des des tenues
religieuses dans pour les
accompagnatrices scolaires il peut pas y
avoir de poids de mesure la République
doit être ferme ce message de fermeté où
on l'adresse au monde entier où on
n'adresse pas mais quand on est dans le
en même temps dans le
entre deux comme on l'est sur le texte
immigration on va y venir mais Gérard
Larché la semaine dernière il disait que
la classe politique avait été faible
face au communautarisme face aux
atteintes à la laïcité toute la classe
politique a été faible en tout cas il y
en a qui ont été beaucoup plus faibles
que d'autres et on le voit bien encore
sur le profil de l'assassin de ce
professeur de français ou des
associations de gauche et d'extrême
gauche des partis politiques avait
réclamé et obtenu l'annulation de la
mesure d'expulsion de la famille s'il
s'était pas mobilisé à l'époque
croyez-moi euh on en serait pour faire
respecter la circulaire Vals non non non
non non il y avait des moyens il y avait
des moyens de l'expulser bien et on ne
l'a pas fait mais mais en même temps
est-ce que c'est pas aussi la droite qui
a mis cette condition que quand on
arrive en France avant l'âge de 13 ans
on n'est pas expulsable mais moi je suis
j'ai aucun souci j'ai critiqué depuis le
premier jour euh ce qu'on a appelé le le
renoncement sur la double peine
quand j'ai fait campagne sur LR j'ai
fait campagne aussi en disant faut le
droit d'inventaire voilà et si c'est
sous
Nica mais bien sûr mais il y a une
graduation hein et pour avoir fait pas
mal de plateaux de Radio Télévision très
souvent lorsque on réclame des mesures
très très fermes sur l'immigration
qu'est-ce qu'on nous répond on y répond
oh là là vous êtes
admiifasciste vous avez le même langage
que l'extrême droite il y a cette
conivance médiatique aussi pas seulement
politique est-ce que juste pour sur
Dominique Bernard tu es pas un
terroriste islamiste qui était suivi par
les services de renseignement est-ce que
pour vous il y a eu des failles est-ce
que vous souhaitez une commission
d'enquête là-dessus bien sûr qu'il y a
eu des failles mais c'est pas une on
peut faire des commissions d'enquête
mais on sait quasiment tout mais non
mais on sait tout voilà c'est en réalité
un individu qui avait fait l'objet de de
mesures d'éloignement du territoire par
sa famille lorsqu'il était mineur et à
titre personnel lorsqu'il était majeur
il était inexpulsable pourquoi elle
était inexpulsable parce que il y a une
règle en France et la règle elle est
trouée comme un gruyaire par des
exceptions les exceptions tuent la règle
de l'expulsion et les exceptions
finissent par tuer des Français voilà et
bien nous dans le texte sur
l'immigration on annulera les exceptions
on on va en parler juste avant les sur
les les commissions d'enquête il y a une
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur le
signalement et le traitement des
pressions menaces et agression dont les
enseignants sont victimes aujourd'hui au
Sénat cet après-midi à 15h Michel paatti
la sœur de Samuel paatti sera
auditionnée est-ce que vous assisterez à
cette commission qu'est-ce que vous à
cette audition qu'est-ce que vous en
attendez en tout cas j'avais été un de
ceux qui avaiit pousser cette commission
d'enquête au moment où elle avait fait
paraître la sœur de Monsieur Paty son
livre voilà et bien moi je pense
jeonathan qu'on prenne la mesure des
choses parce que depuis l'assassinat de
Monsieur Paty un certain nombre d'études
dont Jean-Pierre Aubin parlait qui est
l'ancien inspecteur de l'Éducation
nationale qui est connu pour un certain
nombre de de ces livres les territoires
perdu de la République et cetera mais
beaucoup d'enquêtes nous ont montré que
les enseignants considèrent que il y a
pas eu l'éducation nationale n'a pas
tiré les conséquences toutes les
conséquences de la décapitation de
Samuel paatti et on voit bien que ils
sont de plus en plus aujourd'hui les
enseignants à s'autocensurer parce
qu'ils craignent à évoquer un certain
nombre de sujets la choix et beaucoup
d'autres sujets donc on a rien réglé il
faut une fermeté absolue cette fermeté
absolue elle ne peut pas s'accompagner
du en même temps de de ces virages je
parlais de la nomination de Monsieur PAP
il faut vraiment une une constance et
une cohérence c'est à ce prix et ça ça
ne se traitera pas en une journée bien
entendu mais c'est vraiment avec une
sorte de
rectitude moralement qu'on parviendra
justement à faire à reculer l'islamisme
Stéphane sur la loi immigration sur la
loi immigration est-ce que est-ce que le
meurtre de Dominique Bernard ce vendredi
est de nature à faire changer les
républicains de position sur ce texte
vous voulez rire non je vous pose la
question non mais vous vous vous vous
utilisez les arguments du ministre de
l'Intérieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
le ministre non non mais c'est pas
vis-à-vis de vous Stéphan Vern ne vous
inquiétez pas simplement c'est
incroyable nous on veut durcir le texte
et le ministre d'intérieur dit bah on
espère que les républicains vont voter
un texte molasson il en est hors de
question c'est pas c'est pas exactement
ce qu'il dit il dit que le texte qui a
été voté par la commission des lois il y
a quelques mois aurait permis
l'expulsion de cet assaillant mais que
si vous êtes prê a plus de fermeté il
est prêt à vouser non non mais il il non
non il a dit il faut que les LR vote
bahà parce qu'il y a une urgence une
urgenceement le texte le texte d'abord
il est muet sur plein de choses sur le
code de la nationalité il est muet sur
les mineurs non accompagnés il est sur
le regroupement familial la commission
des lois a fait son travail et on l'a
durci mais il faut le durcir encore donc
encore plus que la version qui est
sortie de la commission des lois bien
sûr c'est l'objectif depuis le départ on
n' pas changé ici on change pas on
retourne pas notre veste tous les matins
au Sénat on a une ligne et on essaie de
la de la suivre qu'est-ce qu'on va
changer on va changer par exemple le
fait d'arrêter les pompes aspirantes on
a déjà trop de pompes aspirantes par
exemple sur les soins gratuit pour les
étrangers par exemple sur le
regroupement familial par exemple sur le
droit d'asile mais là le gouvernement
veut installer une nouvelle pompe
aspirante en donnant un droit
automatique à ceux qui ont fraudé qui
sont en situation irrégulière sur le
territoire on leur donne un droit
automatique à la régularisation mais
est-ce que c'est ce que veulent les
Français aujourd'hui les Français
veulent vraiment qu'on accepte des
étrangers qui fraudent qui sont des
clandestins et qui vont avoir un droit
opposable c'est-à-dire automatique à la
régularisation pardon mais c'est pas non
plus ce que dit le gouvernement il dit
c'est pas un appel d'air il y aura des
conditions strictes ce sont des gens qui
sont déjà là et qui travaillent déjà sur
le territo vous voulez rire si vous
dites aux gens venez en France il suffit
d'être clandestin de travailler dans un
métier ention tout les métiers sont
enenstion partout en France dans toutes
les régions françaises et alors vous
obtiendrez le Graal vous serez
régularisé croyez que c'est pas un appel
d'air bien sûr que si vous ne pouvez pas
maîtriser le chaos migratoire sans
message de fermeté chaque fois que vous
faites un trou c'est pas les pauvres
migrants qui viennent du sel qui sont
informés c'est les filières c'est les
mafias c'est les trafiquants d'êtres
humains relisez il y a 15 jours le monde
qui indiquait en questionnant h femmes
qui avaient été tout était violé est-ce
que c'est ce qu'on veut est-ce qu'on
veut accélérer ces mouvements
migratoires qui n' sont qu'à leur début
si on veut les accélérer évidemment on
crée des trous dans la raquette donc cet
article 3 c'est toujours une ligne rouge
pour vous sur régularisation des métiers
en tenstion est-ce que si les sorties du
texte est passé via une circulaire c'est
un compromis acceptable pour vous nous
il les choses sont très claires vous
avez deux options possibles la première
option qu'a choisi le gouvernement c'est
la loi qui donne ce droit automatique à
la régularisation pour ceux qui ont
frudé il n'en est pas question et puis
il y a de tout temps un pouvoir
discrétionnaire donné au préfet environ
7000 par an c'est très différent la
différence entre le droit automatique et
le pouvoir discrétionnaire c'est qu'un
préfet va pas seulement contrôler s'il y
a bien un emploi dans un secteur en
tension mais il va aussi contrôler à
360°r la capacité d'assimilation de
l'individu et ça reste bien sûr
exceptionnel donc hors de question de
passer par la loi en revanche le pouvoir
discrétionnaire des préfets de l'État
c'est
Unis il y a pas de compromis possible
c'est pas un compromis situation moment
à un moment est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'il soit voté ce texte ah mais moi je
suis non je ne souhaite qu' est-ce que
vous souhaitez qu' qu' ait une loi
immigration je souhaite qu'il y ait une
loi immigration utile nous ne voterons
pas écoutez-moi bien si demain nous ne
parviens si nous ne parvenons pas si
nous av'ons pas la majorité par exemple
pour supprimer l'article 3 nous ne
voterons pas le texte hors de question
de tricher avec les Français on est à la
22e ou 23e loi en 25 ans qu'est-ce que
ça a changé vous m'interrogiez il y a
quelques années pour la loi colon sous
Emmanuel Macron et on me disait ah oui
mais c'est beaucoup plus ferme en même
temps on faisait le regroupement
familial on élargissait les conditions
de regroupement familial pour les
mineurs non accompagné heureusement que
le Sénat dit non à cette loi puisque
l'année d'après c'était une explosion en
matière de titre de séjour
mais est-ce que vous l'avez la majorité
parce que là-dessus sur cet article 3
vous êtes un peu isolé les centristes la
gauche la majorité présidentielle ne
sont pas d'accord avec il y a un
dialogue avec nos amis centristes et je
pense que nous trouverons un point
d'atterrissage pour qu'il n'y ait ni
article 3 ni article 4 voilà mais
aujourd'hui les Français sont excédés on
peut pas faire semblant avec eux ou
c'est un texte qui est utile ou il ne
l'est pas mais j'ajoute j'ajoute que
malheureusement aujourd'hui
quand un parlementaire quand le
Parlement vote la loi les cours suprêmes
la détricotent inverse les choses je
vais vous montrer un exemple très
concret après Samuel paatti il y a le
texte contre le séparatisme je fais
passer au Sénat une disposition qui sera
voté à l'Assemblée nationale et qui sera
dans la loi c'est quoi cet amendement
que je fais passer au Sénat le fait de
pouvoir retirer un titre de sesjour ou
refuser un titre de séjour à un
étranger qui ne respecte pas les
principe de République c'est simple la
liberté conscience croire ou ne pas
croire la légalité homme ou femme ça
devient loi le Conseil constitutionnel
en août 2021 abroche cette disposition
parce que pour lui les principes de la
République c'est trop flou vous rendez
compte donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous voulons nous et nous avons
proposé une modification
constitutionnelle nous voulons un
référendum nous voulons élargir
l'article 11 qui permettrait d'avoir un
référendum sur cette question tout ça
simplement parce que quand le peuple
tranche le Conseil constitutionnel
s'incl et cette révision
constitutionnelle est-ce que vous allez
l'inscrire rapidement à l'ordre du jour
du Sénat le 12 décembre prochain donc
juste après le vote du budget le 12
décembre prochain parce qu'on n pas des
niches toutes les semaines donc bien sûr
sur sur l'ensemble de ces sujets vous
aurez vous aurez une une majorité
cohérente et construite cette fois-ci
entre le le le le les républicains du
Sénat les républicains de l'Assemblée
j'espère bien j'espère bien sur la
révision constitutionnelle oui vous me
posez surigration oui parce qu'après il
faut qu'elle aille à l'Assemblée la
révision constitutionnelle une fois
qu'elle a été examinée au Sénat est-ce
que les députés alr vous ont dit qu'il
le reprendrait dans le je je je vous
rappelle que ces deux textes la loi
ordinaire la loi constitutionnelle nous
les avons déposé avec OL marlex eticti
ensemble bien sûr donc il y aura pas de
surpriseise juste pour revenir un peu en
arrière sur la immigration sur la
question de laassillant puisque Gérald
haranan dit que avec le texte qui a été
voté par la commission du des lois du
Sénat pardon la saillandaras aurait pu
être expulsé est-ce que vous dites la
même chose ou est-ce que vous dites non
il faut encore durcir et on prendra des
mesures pour durcir encore plus c'est
une nouvelle carabistouille c'est un peu
compliqué je vais essayer d'être clair
en réalité il a pas pu être expulsé
puisque la mesure d'expulsion quand on
arrive avant 13 ans c'est quasiment
impossible très bien Géral armmanin ne
modifie pas ce point-là puisqu'il aurait
fallu c'est ce qu'il affirme pourant
attendez il ne modifie pas ce point-là
il il la maudit un petit peu en disant
mais si quelqu'un estible d'une peine de
prison et cetera suffisante on pourrait
plus facilement l'expulser même s'il
arrive avant 13 ans lui ce qu'il modifie
c'est le régime des OQTF des obligations
de quitter le territoire français euh
avant 13 ans mais il y a une grande
différence entre l'expulsion et leqtf
leqtf le taux de réussite le taux
comment dirais-je où on parvient
àexulsion réelle ouis laissé passer
consulaire il est de moins de 7 % de
moins de 7 %. il y a en 2022 euh c'était
un peu plus de 9000 sur 134000 vous
rendez compte donc ça ne marche pas en
revanche
l'expulsion le taux est de quasiment 49
% alors c'est beaucoup moins bien sûr
mais surtout pour une expulsion c'est
beaucoup plus fort parce que quand il y
a un recours auprès de la justice
administrative il y a pas de suspension
voilà et le retour il est définitif
quand vous expulsez il y a pas de billet
retour possible pour la France donc vous
voyez bien ce que nous on fera nous pour
le Tex c'est qu'on supprimera pour
l'expulsion pour l'expulsion toutes les
exceptions dont dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui sont en train d'affaiblir et
même de tuer la
règle on va passer à la question
d'Israël vous souhaitiez mettre à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat demain soir une
proposition de résolution pour condamner
les crimes du Hamas et soutenir les
Israéliens le gouvernement a refusé le
gouvernement refuse c'est incroyable
pour c'est incroyable ce qu'on nous dit
dans les couloirs c'est le quai d'orset
le quai d'orset refuse parce qu'il
craint que
sitsal entre dans Gaza le même jour ou
avant qu'il ait des dommages collatéraux
mais ce qui est incroyable ça veut dire
que au quai d'orset le gouvernement
français mais sur le même plan une
action en légitime défense d'Israël et
un crime contre l'humanité enfin ces
images d'une violence paroxistique
inouie elles n'ont pas choqué les
membres du gouvernement ces enfants qui
sont égorgés qui sont décapités
seulement parce qu'ils étaient juifs un
enfant c'est le symbole de de
l'innocence que pourtant Emmanuel Macron
a très clairement condamné et il a dit
très clairement qu' fait Israël donc
pour vous vous dites il y a ce qui dit
ce qui c'est le relativisme c'est la
mise sur le même plan de de choses qui
ne le sont pas et c'est en même temps un
profond mépris pour le Parlement quoi le
Parlement ne pourrait pas de façon
adulte
responsable assumer une discussion on ne
peut pas nous se saisir d'un moment qui
est dramatique et dont on a vu par
ailleurs des conséquences dans notre
pays on n'aurait pas le droit d'en
discuter à travers une résolution mais
mais c'est quoi ce gouvernement pourquoi
méprise-t-il autant le Parlement le
Parlement c'est l'manation de la volonté
générale des Français nous sommes les
représentants des Français les brasment
sont tombés et je sais que sans trahir
de
secret
jaradarcher a eu le ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement hier
aprèsmidi croyez-moi cette conversation
téléphonique il s'en souviendra
longtemps et du coup ils vont revenir
sur cette décision quoi je ne sais pas
s'ils vont revenir sur cette décision
mais mais vous les appelez à revenir sur
cette décision et à l'inscrire
rapidement l'Our bien entendu bien
entendu il se déshonore il se déshonore
vis-à-vis de ce qui s'est passé en
Israël il se déshonore vis-à-vis du
Parlement français est-ce que ça
affaibli aussi la voix de la France mais
mais bien sûr que ça affaiblit la voix
de la France on on voit bien qu'on est
toujours dans un entre deux et
malheureusement il fut un temps où
peut-être que le monde s'écrivait en
nuances aujourd'hui les nuances
malheureusement elles sont souvent pas
là et il faut trancher trancher dans le
vif être clair être net c'est à ces
conditions simplement qu'on peut diriger
un pays dans un monde qui devient de
plus en plus menaçant toute marque de
faiblesse est exploité contre nous toute
marque de faiblesse est exploitée contre
nous il y a des questions qui se posent
sur nos relations avec certains pays et
qui ont d'ailleurs été posé la semaine
dernière lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement notamment sur nos
relations avec le Qatar est-ce qu'il
faut les revoir c bien sûr qu'il faut
les revoir on a des dispositifs une
convention fiscale qui est outrageuse
avantageuse voilà donc revoyons ce genre
de relation c'est pas parce que le Qatar
finance une équipe de foot en France qui
est une belle équipe de foot que il faut
être à leur genou bien sûr que non et
aujourd'hui on est à leur genoux pour
vous mais il y a une complicité bien sûr
il y a il y a une forme de complicité
moi je demande à en
sortir
Stéphane est-ce que vous approuvez la
démarche du du sénateur LR des des boues
du rô Stéphane Le rudulier qui demande
la dissolution de parti qui l'accuse
d'avoir fait l'apologie du terrorisme
après les attaque du 7 octobre en Israël
dont la France insoumise comme Stéphane
rolier moi je suis mais
abassourdi choqué par la plupart des
membres de lesfi heureusement certains
ont sauvé l'honneur qui refusent de
qualifier de terroriste ce qui a eu lieu
ce crime contre l'humanité que le Hamas
a commis contre le peuple israélien
c'est lamentable et on voit bien que
lellef fille depuis longtemps a quitté
l'arc républicain lorsque en 2019 il
battait le pavé à Paris au côté du CCIF
ce sont des islamo gauchistes et dans
cette manifestation à l'époque on criait
on y criait mort aux juifs depuis
sainseline et tant d'autres choses la
police tu en fait ces gens-là veulent
ébranler la République ils veulent
mettre à bas la République ils sont
sortis de l'arc républicain maintenant
je pense malheureusement que pour ce qui
concerne la proposition c'est très
compliqué puisque c'est un mouvement
politique en France les conditions
juridiques rendent les choses très très
compliquées moi ce que je souhaite en
tout cas c'est que LF revienneent sur
des principes républicains responsaes ça
crée des distensions au sein de l'anub
c'estce qu'elle va exploser en vol un
pour vous vous pensez mais je mais
j'espère comment se fait-il mais mais
comment se fait-il que des gens qui sont
des républicains de gauche qui soi du
PCF du PS euh ou ou d'autres mouvances
écologistes tolèent cette alliance là
cette alliance elle est fondamentalement
coupable vous imaginez si nous on
faisait des alliances avec à l'inverse
sur le côté droit avec des mouvements
qui euh seraient des mouvements
totalement complices de l'islamisme et
donc du terrorisme mais mais mais chaque
matin on nous désignerait parce que
c'est la gauche personne dit rien moi je
pense que c'est irresponsable la nupess
c'est la marque d'un déshonneur
politique une dernière question juste
sur Israël puisque Joe Biden se rend en
Israël demain est-ce qu'immanuel Macron
doit s'y rendre pour vous il pourrait
parfaitement s'y rendre oui bien sûr
pourrait parfaitement s r le il faut
bien savoir et bien comprendre que
beaucoup de choses nous unissent à
Israël et et au peuple juif il y a ces
ces liens qui sont des liens
irrévocables qui sont des liens
historiques tu sais dans nos racines
judéo-chrétienne il a ses liens aussi
d'ordre civique quielle porte au
Moyen-Orient les valeurs de la
démocratie et et il y a aussi tous ces
Français qui sont qui sont morts ou qui
sont retenus en otage donc ce qui nous
concerne là-bas nous concerne ici
évidemment et je pense que ce sans
vererser de français une vingtaine sont
morts et et d'autres malheureusement
sont tenus en otage font que on a parti
lié ensemble une dernière question
Stéphane plus régionale oui sur le une
question d'antaise sur l'aéroport
d'antatl aussi que il y avait un appel
d'offre pour transformer l'aéroport qui
a fait choublanc les travaux sont
reportés d'au moins 2 ans s'ils
aboutissent un jour alors que la
promesse de transformation l'aéroport
accompagnait l'annulation l'abandon du
projet de notreddame des land est-ce que
vous en tant qu'élu de l'Ouest est-ce
que vous dites que finalement c'est pas
plus mal que l'écologie a eu a eu gain
de cause ou où est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment de vous êtes fait bien avoir
dans cette histoire on s bien fait avoir
moi je me suis pas fait avoir hein parce
que j'étais réaliste depuis le départ
c'est simplement tout simplement on a
donné ceux qui ont gagné c'est les
ultraviolents on a donné un permis de
casser à ceux qui étaient les plus
violents il y a eu un référendum qui
avait été gagné pour notre lande il y a
eu 179 décisions de tribunaux européens
mais aussi français qui ont tous été
gagnés et bien malgré tout
el Macron Édouard Philippe aussi pour
simplement s'attirer les faveurs d'un
éphémère ministre de l'Environnement qui
était Nicolas HULLOT on sacrifié notre
land ils ont fait des belles promesses
ils ont fait des très belles promesses
parce que on nous avait dit mais on sera
relié avec le TGV plus facilement à
Paris que neni rien n'est avancé vous
aurez un aéroport nonatlantique qui sera
rénové total c'est c'est un désastre
enfin les les les voyageurs sont très
très mal accueilli et les conditions
même de la sécurité peuvent être
interrogées c'est scandaleux c'est un
dossier scandaleux qui est la faute
originelle sur le plan de l'autorité de
l'État d'Emmanuel Macron puisque ça sert
à rien de combattre les adistes à
saintsis si on leur a donné raison avant
à Notre Dame des land merci Bruno merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin la Une de West France Stéphane
c'est cet hommage à Dominique Bernard
l'hommage national de l'école à ses
professeurs oui c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup on passe au club
des territoire